breathing some podcast Ville it's
Thursday the 24 to the month the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy sell
stocks ETFs options encrypt those or
Commission free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just the wealthy let me tell you that my
wife has been having a blast at this
thing I don't know what I'm doing but
she knows what she's doing and she tells
folks to everybody about Robin Hood so
I'm telling you what I'm gonna do for
you Robin Hood has given the church
what's happening now family a free stock
like apple for the sprint to help you
build your portfolio you know sound kind
of zhenia again Robin Hood is giving you
guys the church family a stock like
apple for the Sprint to help you build
your portfolio I want you to sign up at
church dot Robin Hood calm again
sign up at church dot Robin Hood dot-com
that's church dot Robin Hood dot-com no
Commission's no fees no nothing learn by
doing go to Robin Hood dot need to go to
church dot Robin Hood dot-com listen a
new year means new resolutions and we've
got one we are working on twice every
day it's your oral health and with
crippling Trump electric toothbrush
sticking to good habits is nice and
simple the guiding features I like
built-in support system for better
brushing I use it my wife uses it and my
daughter uses it I gotta tell you
something we love it the motions the
timer everything how feels in your hand
how easy it is to travel which all I
tell you what I love with that's why I
love quip and why over million happy
people and helping mouths due to clip
starts at $25 so if you're gonna get
quick calm right now again get quit
g-e-t QE u IP dot-com right now you can
get your first refill pack for free I
just got my refills two days ago maybe
Saturday maybe Friday what they're gonna
do is clips
to 24 hours and if you go to get quick
calm slash Joey right now you're gonna
get your first refill pack for free
that's your first refill pack for free
and get quick calm slash Joey
kick that melee even if you started a
resolution you already [__] it up
listen restart again you know I'm saying
that's why I don't like resolutions and
I want to do something a new year I
started December so there's no pressure
so by January it sticks you follow me
anyway it's Thursday the 24th I hope you
guys are doing well today I get emails a
lot I get a I don't have the Gmail page
no more because I lost it you know every
time I I got a new computer the [__]
cold disappeared or something and then
there was a point when I had to Gmail
pages and I don't get to I don't have
them that all no more now so if you're
sending messages to the Gmail and I
haven't gotten back to here it's not cuz
I don't like it cuz I don't even know
how to get them or they're [__]
disappeared but I do find a lot of
facebook Messenger pages and regular
Facebook a lot of [__] people I've
been hitting me up lately
and yeah it's a lot of like you know we
saw this we saw that we went to see you
we're going to see but it's also a lot
of questions a lot of questions about
like growth and the one thing people
have the hardest problem with that we
all did listen you know he is decisions
it's the decision to do something stick
with it and believe in it you know when
I get these emails I look at him and
people like well I got this offered to
me and it's not about it's not correct
it's not comedy questions their career
questions they're they're drug choices
there well I say drug choices somebody
was trying to get off drugs okay so it
says you know they they they saw
something they came to a reality and
they hit me up because they want to tell
me they're clean eleven days or
something like that and these are all
great things I love all this kind of
stuff
but the thing I I see that people
struggle with the most so I thought
about it for a few weeks and I wrote
about it you know and it's making that
decision because there's the moment of
reality there's the moment of okay I've
been doing this for this long and it's
gotten me nowhere what is my next step
do I quit what I'm doing do I go to
something else do I move on to something
else how much longer do I give this is
the number one question that people have
don't think I had it it was crazy you
know and I started this at 28 so at 35
when I was broke everybody else had
money around them and I'm still [__]
living like a [__] bumpy you know
like you know anthem out and I'm still a
sort of an open mic in 95 seven years
later so or at 90 whatever the [__] I'm
trying to say to you people
it's the decision to to do something and
stick with it it's [__] hard it's
hard it's hard to go okay I'm gonna quit
my job where I get six hundred a week
eight hundred a week twelve hundred week
insurance ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba to do
a commissioned job that yeah I can make
two hundred thousand a year but the
first six months I'm a little little bit
on my means well you put away some money
and then you'll say well joy what if it
what if I don't start making money after
six months then don't take the job
because you're already lost in your mind
you already lost in your mind you know
when you when you take those type of
leaps there's a lot of things to
consider when you're single who gives a
[__] go for it if it fails you failed
it's on your shoulders and you start all
over again you can [__] bounce off
from that [__] it's when you're married
and have somebody else on your shoulders
and have a child that those decisions
are tough you know now is when we talk
about the comedy aspect of it because I
compare the comedy aspect and the other
thing one
it's a job or anything you know how long
do you stick with it before you tell you
know how long do you stand McDonald's
how long would you stay at McDonald's if
you started working at McDonald's at 18
to help you go through college how long
do you stand McDonald's for you know you
stand McDonald's until one day you say
I'm not mopping this [__] floor no
more because one of the promotions at
McDonald Mandy you're in the back you're
in the front then you become an
assistant manager then they move here
then they give you a store eighty-two
thousand miles from your house today
you're a manager at you know everything
has a breaking point I got I have
friends here that still have their same
job that they've had to stay quit high
school but I know that sometimes they
hurt because they wanted to do something
else but at the same time they couldn't
because they had a wife and kids you
know it's it's it's not easy to make a
life-changing decision when you have
wife and kids that takes real balls but
that also takes belief that's the second
part of the come conversation so you
realize something you know what if let's
be honest in two thousand and whatever
11 or whatever the [__] I was not sad I
was not angry I was not depressed I just
didn't think I could do what everybody
else had done I never saw myself playing
a theater I saw myself headlining I was
headlining a lot of rooms but I wasn't
really a headliner and I took some time
off before I went to the store and I
said you don't want if I'm not gonna do
the store and I'm just gonna go on the
road or rogue I gotta give myself a
homework assignment every week I'm happy
I did this and every week Thursday night
I would drive to the [__] horrifying
improv and I would sneak in the back and
I would sit there with
sometimes I put sunglasses on it was the
creepiest [__] I ever did and I watched
every headliner for about nine or ten
months from greg Giraldo the big black
dude that i got rest his soul
I watched Ralphie I watched everybody I
could hadn't seen Jim Gaffigan anybody
who played the herbal improv that year I
watched him on the drive home I came to
a conclusion that I was fake headlining
like I was a fake headliner I had to
figure out something to put my jokes
together not I was just another comic
telling jokes between Greg Geraldo
Ralphie the big black guy there was a
lot of comics when I went home thinking
about their act even if I didn't like
them personally or whatever at least I
learned something from them that I had
to do oh yeah oh yeah can't imagine that
they talked about this at the Irvine
improv and I knew that I had a [__]
do something with my life but I tell you
what I didn't want to put the work in
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I was like
right now at this point in my life I'm
happy I'm booking commercials I'm
booking TV shows my friends have TV
shows they give me between the rogen
work [__] the work that I get the
commercials I book I can make a simple
living
I can't mean it wouldn't be a hundred
grand but I can make a simple living and
want a job I can make make a hundred
grand I'd be [__] happier than [__]
to me that that you know I'm not doing
coke I'm not on jets I'm not our party
and I don't give a [__] I was pretty
content with that I really was I the
reality was that I had done movies that
done TV shows and I hadn't moved the
meter on my standup the meter of my
standup had not moved and hey it happens
but some people do one line in a [__]
movie and the next week they're selling
out theaters that didn't happen for me
at all and I saw the movie thing and I
saw the TV thing and the recurring
still just wasn't moving and I didn't
know how to make it move I had no idea
how to make it move
and in February 18th this year our is
doing a show at The Comedy Store Monday
the 18th and Tuesday is my birthday
February 19th and I asked Ari why was he
doing that show and he goes because it
was the 9th anniversary of the first
time we did the storytellers show in the
lab in the back of the improv and I go
was nine [__] years ago was me Marc
Maron and somebody else
I forget who else was it was and it was
in the back and there was maybe 30 or 40
people back there and I wasn't involved
in how a certain story but while I was
sitting there I thought about the wall
story I was kind of a ticket to the wall
me and Joe for Karachi oh & lubes and
him flicking the cigarette Michelle I
just told the whole thing and how it led
up and that's when storytelling came up
so think about it I was ready to quit
doing comedy on the road because I
needed something to tie together the
pieces if not I wouldn't have grown and
next thing you know storytelling comes
along and that was the piece I needed at
the time
I didn't know my stories were gonna work
I didn't know people gonna turn into
them but I jumped on that bandwagon and
it lifted my stand up a little bit so
not it wasn't that I was quitting and so
I came to realization that if I went on
the road I was only go on the road for
30 people a night
yeah people knew me from the Rogan
podcast and people know me from [__]
the longest shard and doing [__] like
that
but I wouldn't have come to that
opportunity which that's what it was was
not pitoni that opened up storytelling
oh my god now I've been telling these
stories to these comics for years
whenever I went to New York with Rogen I
would point to different places and they
would go why don't you talk about these
on stage I go cuz nobody wants to
[__] arrow
but that's the direction I took that was
the decision I took and now if you come
watch me I'm kind of a storyteller who
tells jokes well at least the joke has
an explanation with the story or the
story has an explanation for the joke so
I had that gap in the road because
everybody told me was television in the
film I attacked that and the answer was
right in front of me and it was the work
I had to put in so now I had to start
sitting down and writing stories and
thinking about [__] and ask him my
friend my friends stupid [__]
questions and they're going why you
asking me these questions and they'd
bring up a story then they'd add another
story to it and it was a really great
process that I went to but going back to
realization like I was running around
amuck until 1984 and then 1984 I came to
a lot of realizations I came to the
realization then I was a [__] [__]
I came to the realization that I was a
drug at not really I didn't come to that
realization when I was a drug addict at
that point I just had a realization but
that was a [__] [__] and be that I
wasn't gonna do anything in my life that
I was done I gave up at the age of 21
years old I was like I'm just gonna be a
[__] piece of [__] and a bummer then
we're gonna get nowhere and it was
because of five years had gone by and
done done with my life I thought that
the world was going to hand you
something see I thought the world was
gonna hand me like a union book and I
was gonna make $23 an hour and drive a
Corvette it didn't work that way and
then after that realization came wasn't
the drugs came in and then thanks to God
I met a nice I bumped into an old friend
and he took me to a meeting and that's
when I realized I was addicted or
whatever the [__] words they use or
whatever and I got clean but 84 was the
realization period in my life when I
realized that Jesus Christ I'm gonna
know this [__] and then I started
getting the pieces together and I got
into it Colorado Mountain College
even while I was taking classes I would
say to myself why am i taking these
classes I'm never gonna get no away with
them and I kept taking the classes and I
kept signing up for semesters and I'm
like why am I paying a hundred eighty I
wall because if you know anything about
me how I acknowledge I want to keep
learning just cuz I dropped out didn't
mean I didn't want to keep learning it
just wasn't the situation I can go to
school and then actually you know I get
in trouble I move to Boulder and I
joined continuing and emboldened at the
two years in Boulder they come to me and
they go hey you could transfer into our
school now Here I am a [__] high
school dropout and the University of
Colorado thinks I have a [__] Drive
ah a high school diploma I don't know
who told them that and they're allowing
me to go into the [__] college and
I'm sitting there going this cannot be
[__] happening
so I'm actually going for this [__]
college then they send me then they said
yet come in and fill out an application
one time there you take the application
home fill it out I lied everywhere it
probably says high school diploma yeah
and they said you gotta send it in I
[__] lied they sent it in and then
they said would meet you at the high
school diplomas and then I kept going
back and forth but then I couldn't find
it my high school couldn't find that I
had to make calls like principals that I
knew or you know out of school and I
would talk to me go listening University
of Colorado calls Todd I have a diploma
and then one of them said one we just
print one up and fake it and I mean I
had a thousand options wait that was one
of the principal said that one of my
high school principals were all on the
bar he was out there he retired because
we could get you one and just put your
name in there I mean it was hilarious
and I was like this not a bad idea let
me get back to you know all that [__]
[__] I got arrested Wow
so when I got arrested I was forced to
go in there tell the counselor the truth
and tell them that I was gonna get my
GED and they didn't give a [__] he was a
that's fine go get your GED what make
you the same way with a high school
diploma because I was poverty no plan
but this is not even where I ended up
it's so crazy that yeah
once I got into the University of
Colorado guys and I started taking
classes the weirdest thing happened I
realized that the same one I want to do
anyway what am i what what am I gonna
get out of this any degree I get I can't
get a job in it the original plan was to
go back to it the original plan was to
go back from New York and get a job on
Wall Street now that I got the felonies
I can't even go back to I can't get a
job on Wall Street so I had one option
to go back and sell windows doors and
sashes for a door company out of
Richfield Park New Jersey that was my
option they probably don't require a
college degree they just want to do this
so they know my situation they knew I
was a good salesman they just wanted me
to [__] sell but that didn't sound
like fun to you it was like 68 year to
start plus bonus isn't a car it sounded
great for a guy like me at that
situation it sounded great
but I had also had another thought in
between all that that scared the [__]
out of me everybody has a fear there's
some people have a fear growing old
there's some people wonder you young
there's some people have fears of
different things I'm not talking about
Heights and stuff I'm talking about
situations
some people have fear of staying with
somebody for a long time I don't know
what that's called my [__] fear from
the age of 20 to 35 was that I wasn't
gonna amount anything
every time up to the age of 35 every
time I saw an old guy with a rock
t-shirt on and a pony tail I got a knot
in my [__] so much every time I saw a
guy who was old and was doing a
youngsters job like a hard carrier or
or like I don't know it scared me
it would [__] him petrified me because
that was the person I'd rather kill
myself before I'd become a 50 year old
that worked at Subway sandwich I'm not I
have nothing against 50 year olds and I
have nothing at Subway sandwich but just
the fact of a 50 year old me working at
Subway sandwich with two 20 year olds
that are in college talking about how
cool I was at that one on the Sunset
Strip and I met Richard Pryor one time I
didn't think that was kosher I didn't
think that was gonna fly for me I would
have hated myself so I knew I had to do
something before I got [__] old but
that was my biggest fear that was my
biggest fear was not amounting to
anything at least at this company I
could be a Salesman get a pension and
maybe six or seven years be the leader
of the sales force and maybe after that
go and train salesmen at places at
corporations or that was the plan then
like that was the plan that was it
that's all I had when I got out of
prison that's all I had but the thing
that scared me the most was retiring at
65 and getting a watch and working for a
company for 40 years and one day just
stopping like that scared the [__] out
of me too but nothing like just being
like a 50 year old that lives it two
other guys he's still smoking pot he
still has a ponytail I'd still be doing
blow nothing scared me more than that
that's who I did not want to be somebody
age of 35 I was [__] fighting hard to
not end up like that so in 1995 which I
was 32 years old I decided [__] gone
for calm
this is what I'm gonna do I tried the
college thing I tried the family thing I
tried the dad thing I'm not good at any
of these things calmly might be the way
to [__] go and once I went for it
I did not look back at all guys I could
tell you one thing from the bottom of my
heart I didn't look back for two reasons
I had nothing to look back for and I had
nowhere else to go right now Lee has a
mom Lee could tell me the night to go
[__] myself and he could go back to
Boston and probably get a job but that's
all [__] Lee knows he has nowhere
else to go
and there's nothing else that he wants
to do Lee knows that if he goes back to
Boston and lives in his mother's
basement I don't make him happy
but he lost a war you know he won the
war he lost the battle we get the
comfort zones and that's great that's
great I want you to be in a comfort zone
I get him I get the comfort zones
sometimes they're not called laziness
they called comfort zones but then I
forced myself out of the comfort zone
and I do something model of my comfort
zone of them back because I forced
myself to do it you know when I was 32
or like in 1995 I had limited options I
was a [__] father she was five I had
no let's be honest I had no parenting
skills I didn't give a [__] about my
life I can't about one thing because I
really believed that comedy was gonna
save my life
now when you're saying save your life
Joey do you mean living in Beverly Hills
and being Sebastian not by any means at
all I thought that comedy would stop me
from being a thief if I could have just
stopped being a thief and been a human
being I would have been happy as [__]
even if I did the drugs the drugs were
gonna follow me no matter what that was
part of the lifestyle it was part of why
was it was part of the business I was in
I accepted it I just didn't want to be a
[__] thief anymore I did not want to
be a thief and and now I live under now
police scrutiny because but knowing that
the cops could knock on my door at any
minute that's a horrible way to live and
I'd live like that to a [__] angel
you know [__] let's be honest 98 98
so I was a little short of my 40th
birthday the knocks
the cops could knock on my door any time
any time I went home sat down took my
shoes off roll the joint smoked it and
I'd relax eight minutes later I
remembered that the cops could be
looking for me for some men did two
weeks ago I didn't want to live like
that no more so I decided to jump in to
calmly and yeah I'm not gonna lie
I made a couple mistakes in the
beginning of my comedy career that got
me in trouble I got arrested for
fighting like I got arrested [__]
stealing I got arrested for a couple
things gonna be gay but once I fell in
love with it if you look at me after 93
once I fell in love and love and love
with Tommy and I had a path and I had a
direction I never really got in trouble
yet yeah I still did the drugs Joey but
what about the drunks I still did the
drugs that was part of their life that
was probably the law for me that was
what I got into comedy for you know
there's a hundred thousand doctors
there's 200 million [__] attorneys
how many comedians are the nationwide in
the country not that many cuz it's a
hard thing to do and a lot of things
that come with it yeah Joey but Jim
Gaffigan doesn't get high and Brian this
guy doesn't come out yet but I guarantee
the other 50% do it's just a part of
what comes with the occupation you know
look what happened music the last 10
years we lost Michael Jackson we lost
Chris Cornell we lost [__] Tom Petty
we lost Prince you know two [__]
prescription drugs
that's that color
that comes with it whether it's masseuse
or not knowing that comes with about the
musicians before that it comes with it
this is part of the society we're in
today I have a couple friends that I
grew up with that then the kids are
struggling with it right now and I have
other friends that were animals that
that kids don't even know what the
[__] going on it's a 50/50 [__]
chance we got here it's a 50/50 [__]
chance so how do you make your chances
better okay one thing just like I told
this guy I mean then a couple days ago
once you go for it you go for it and
don't think of what if well what if I
fail you just fail and you just felt you
just fail for thinking what if I fell if
you believe in this as much as you're
telling me and if you believe in this in
your heart as much as you're telling me
there's no room for failure because you
won't let it fail do you ever think of
that you won't let it fail that's it
you know before I go onstage every
[__] weekend in a different city
every other weekend I'm [__] my
pants those two hours what am I gonna
say I can have two hours of material and
I'm still saying to you I got nothing to
say I got nothing to say I'm not the
sang I'm nothing to say sometimes it's
good sometimes it's bad
well it's good it's because I forced
myself to write something new or to try
something new and then that carries in
and I got an extra ten minutes or
whatever but when it's bad like I'll say
I'm on the [__] say I got a ton of
[__] to say but I'll shoot myself from
the foot before I even go out I'm a mess
on Thursday night then once I break the
ice on Thursday night I'm good for the
rest of the [__] weekend but it's cuz
I'm not committed in my head once I
commit to my material and I commit to
what I'm gonna do you're in danger
you're in the danger zone because I'm
gonna pound on you I'm gonna just go up
and pound on you but what do you have
felt like [__] I think I think we're the
issues for me is like did you have were
you that confident
ten years ago because I said no I think
the hard part is is when you don't have
that experience to know that things are
gonna be okay
you ever go see somebody and they think
they're [__] funny how it stays there
laughing funny right yeah that's all of
us
that's all of us the first ten years we
think we're a [__] riot but we're not
funny at all right okay we're not funny
at all we and it's but we believe that
we're funny and the bullet and the
believe that were funny and that we're
gonna get funnier gets even stronger you
know the the book on anything that
everybody wants to read let's say you're
an attorney and you go from your [__]
three years of law school and now you're
thrown into the [__] dungeon you
don't even know what the [__] to do but
by doing it every day my going to court
and taking notes and getting this guy
coffee and seeing this guy and he ain't
wait a second he just introduced me to
the DEA from Brooklyn and he just
introduced to the assistant DA from
Queens you meet people and that's called
experience and that's what we're doing
here you can't do stand up in front of
the [__] mirror okay you can't do
stand up in front of the [__] mirror
I would love to tell you that yet comics
practice in front of the mirror though
they don't because you can't get a
reaction it's like when you see a guy
hit in the back yeah he's working on his
conditioning and he's working his
strength and his flexibility in his
cardio but you know what that bag don't
hit back that bag don't hit back okay so
well you all look at Oh got you yeah and
I'm with the bags on him back it's the
same thing with the mirror the mirror
don't hit back if the mirror hey if the
mirror if the mirror [__] could help
you I be at home and I wouldn't even
leave the house I just be in front of
Mara telling jokes to the [__] mirror
and that that's not gonna help your time
and that's not gonna do anything going
out there is it may she do things
same thing of you're a writer I don't
give a [__] listen I am having the
hardest time in the world right in this
[__] book I just rewrote a chapter
for the third [__] time and now and I
mean when I say every write i erase
everything
i erase everything and start from
scratch I told this poor guy I would
have this book by the end of the [__]
January
I just finished rewriting this chapter
for the third [__] time we guess what
guys I like it I like it
before I was telling you a story now I'm
telling you the story before the story
how did I learn that it took me [__]
seven years of [__] writing garbage
at least I'm getting a little bit better
so now what am i doing me redo all the
other [__] proposal chapters because
I think I'm on to something now but how
did I get there because I kept doing it
and I keep doing it when I fly I'll
write for an hour on the way there and
on the way back at the hotel I'll write
again the next one I'll get up and guess
what I'll do I'll erase it why I don't
[__] know but I do it because I don't
like it
I'm not a good writer I could tell you
right now I'm not a good writer but I
know in a year and a half or two years
if I keep doing the little mouths I keep
doing I'll be a better writer and
sometimes I write good for the book and
sometimes I write good for just material
or something like that sometimes I have
great ideas for jokes I just bail on
them because I'm [__] lazy sometimes
I go wow I was writing a joke a couple
weeks ago that I really enjoyed and the
other night when I was on stage I
remembered on the third set at the
Comedy Store Sunday night and they did
it and it worked
I'm like why that bail on that joke is
edible working to it I had a Wikipedia
[__] I had to check dates and [__]
times and a bunch of [__] commitment is
the whole [__] thing and that's the
number one point I'm trying to get
across tonight is when you jump you jump
and you're not gonna have any [__]
problems but if you jump and they'll
look up at your friends and go why
you're gonna fail you're gonna [__]
fail like I said so I got smacked to the
face in 84 and I didn't really go from
my dream well what what it wasn't my
dream wasn't like I had been dreaming
since I was like
had friends that call me an acting class
you don't understand
I used to [__] look look at the hot
pictures of the Hollywood sign I would
hang them up on my wall I always knew
that I would get here guess what
everybody who tell me that is gone right
now everybody who told me about the
Hollywood wall and have a sign the
Hollywood sign all those people had told
me that oh I knew I was always an end up
in Hollywood all those people God God
I'm thinking the two specifically right
now that told me that when they were a
kid they would get the Hollywood sign
out of a magazine hanging on their wall
on the hill we end up in the Hollywood
that God doctors say that people have
told me that that's embarrassing
yeah they would hang him up on their
wall and they hadn't had a big yet they
were still like a waitress or struggling
and they were here like 15 years having
classes the whole [__] thing this
town has really surprised me it
surprised me in two way too but let me
slip by schmuck like me make a living
that's the firth that that's what
everybody believes in this town that
says that can't do it should be
embarrassed because if I'm making a
living acting and doing stupid stand-up
you should be killed me and number two
the other thing I couldn't understand
about this town is how many people were
in love with something and they just
abandon it and I sit there and I think
about them from time to time like when I
go on a drive I don't I don't listen to
music if I want to do a spot so I'm
going to a spot I think about things to
put me through different emotions so
when I get down to the comedy store
whatever club I'm gonna perform at I can
feel different range of emotions you
know I think about a friend dying I
think about a good day I think about a
sad day I think about the day that I was
confused I try to do all those things
when I get on stage I could try to give
you more and I always think about
sometimes not always I think about
people that I was tight with here you
know okay somebody like Ralphie for
example when Ralphie had that apartment
I had conversations with five or six
people different people in that
apartment myself conversations about
comedy and acting or what their dreams
were and why they were gonna do it and
how they're gonna please their parents
bah bah bah those people don't those
people gonna those people are long
[__] God and are we friends on
Facebook now yes no like I'll
communicate with them from time to time
but I could feel you're a little
apprehensive towards me
like they don't know what I'm the same I
have no judgment for them I am listening
everybody has different situations and
everybody has a [__] breaking point
everybody has a breaking point did this
this heart this life out here is [__]
hard a lot of people think they're gonna
throw up
go to a bar bump into Bruce Willis and
their life is gonna be set for a long
time and that's not what it is and when
people realize that they get cracked
like you know I don't know what year I
realized it but once I realized I just
moved on okay this is the way it's gonna
be then I gotta find my niche I just
moved on but there's people that find
out that this is work and they crack
they [__] crack added a girl emailing
me for a couple weeks she had seen me in
the store and she asked me she could
have my information that she was into
marketing or something and then a week
later I'm telling me these [__]
Facebook messages he's sending me and
what she basically wanted what she
thought was let me tell how crazy people
are she thought that I was gonna grab
her by the hand walk her into an agency
this is no live people and that the
agency was gonna pay for her headshots
pay for her acting class and and I
didn't I mean when she told me this I
almost [__] my [__] pants
and I had to ask her to her face that's
a comedy store like when she was telling
me this I go who told you this because
she finally came up to the comedy store
about ten days ago with a head shot out
of the book like I'm standing there
talking to a bunch of people and she
came up out of the blue and she goes hey
can you give this the agent they go my
agent isn't open till January 7th and I
go what's in there she goes a headshot
so let's see it and she took the head
shout out and it was a picture of friend
of taking over and she put it on a Mac
like a [__] thing and then I go this
is the headshot I go there's no name on
it there's nothing
and she goes what you told me just to
take a headshot I go no no no he cuz I
thought she hung out with a bunch acne
she's a young girl
she's a young black girl I put young out
with a bunch at she has that actor he
look to her right now
so she does not my friend told me this
forward you listen I hadn't talked to
the agent yet cuz it was the holidays I
go give me around the seventh or eighth
and I'll call the agent and see what he
needs from me you know I was really
gonna call age like I was really gonna
call make a call for her and see if the
guy could help her you know cuz he told
me he specializes in accents okay got
cheaper with accents you know so after
the headshot was when she told me dad if
I get another headshot there's just me
I'm not doing her accent oh [__] her
accent this she goes does this mean that
you'll take this to your agent of the
throne and he'll pay for my headshots
and pay for my acting class and I go who
told you this and she knows these
actresses I was hanging out with the
other night I go if that's what their
agents do why don't you take that stuff
for them I know this guy a few years I
don't think he's gonna do that right so
she was like well I go first of all you
have a tape like an acting real anything
and she goes I have nothing
I thought you just gonna give this guy
your headshot do you have a resume and
she goes well I have a work resume not
an acting weatherman we have to come up
with something you have to come up with
a page that says your height the color
of your eyes
and who you're studying with and what
commercial workshop you taking you have
to come up with something and I could
see in her face so she was giving me
attitude like she was like getting
insulted and I go what do you expect of
it but this is the only guy know that I
could say this to theatrically like I
just it just so happens that he called
me out of the blue because with the Fox
thing he called me out of the blue and
congratulated me and we started talking
and I go where you work and he told me
he goes
we specialize in kids and accents well
look right in I go you don't sign comics
because unless they're like you know
like from England and stuff like that
right that's what we specialize him
right now so I said okay whatever the
[__] you know so I was gonna take that I
was gonna send her Donaghy's down a
little [__] it's a small office after
she told me that I'm like no so I called
him after the break and I think I'm
bring her up like I didn't even bring
the girl up and then she called me and
that's when she well she hit me up on
Facebook and call me she hit me up on
Facebook and that's that she goes I was
really upset by a conversation you know
that I was told Agence pay for you stuff
maybe you don't want to help me and I go
I do want to help you but you have to
understand that I have my own problems
and I have my own dilemmas if I'm gonna
give somebody a package it's gonna be
the correct way to give him a package I
go and I told him the truth I go I did
speak to him he does want a real he does
want a resume and he does want you to be
in an acting class where you can watch
it this guy's by the book I know this
guy he's really [__] Mike feelings I
just there's just some people by the
book that they want you to be in acting
class they want to come see it at the
acting class
I wouldn't go see anybody in an acting
class but that's there some agents that
they're into that [__] I knew I knew
what school he came from I knew what
agency he was at before and I knew that
one
tried to sign with them he is earlier
Dave put me through the [__] ringer
they put me through the ringer and I had
a real and I had done The Longest Yard
had done spider-man 2 and they were
still like they had had reading about it
and [__] walk around the corner and
talk to casted they wanted me to give
him free casting resumes like people
that are casting directors to give them
3 calls and the director had to do all
this [__]
then they signed me and then my buddy
what I'm talking about right left and I
ended up staying there and then I
stopped getting residual checks I'm like
what the [__] going on sag says I'm
supposed to get a check with the 26th of
January and it's the [__] 1st of
February and I haven't got the check and
then I was supposed to get another check
another check that I can get him I
called sag like what say what's going on
my checks of knowing all we're sending
them to your new agent I go why would
you send him to you in the wagon a sick
cause you signed the paper they're not
inside [__] I go you know anything about
me I live I'm a coke fiend I live off my
[__] residuals and I ran to her
office and I told him to have my [__]
checks and I find them but he had left
already nobody had told me that he had
left why didn't he tell you because he
was embarrassed
ah I finally went to the agents I go
what the [__] you left you to tell me
that you left me I'm sorry I got pulled
in here was a children's agent and they
they want me to take adults with me so
that's what happened so I was over there
and we're getting [__] robbed but the
point being that I couldn't understand
why she just thought that some I could
walk around behind don't are you [__]
crazy
it must work for some people like that's
a scary thing is it must me I mean I I
hate to be mean rude but but maybe those
girls were sleeping with the agents or
maybe they were creepy agents who had
like a really weird deal like they took
your words it rolls but they'll pay for
headshots up front or like that's not a
normal
and that's the weird thing about all
every job in this town is is really not
and pecking order you just kind of you
get in at the bottom level and you work
your way up but there's no it's hard to
even ask anybody else how you did it
because it changes it changes it keeps
changing over and over again and the
table keeps changing you know what they
do with you they won't listen I know
people that went to the comedy store and
two days later they had to top my change
in the top watch manager right just do
that just through the calmness just do
it one day I want tell economy store for
ten years nobody [__] talk to me
nobody said two [__] words to me there
was people want to tell me store and got
an agent and then I got a commercial
agent at the end problem we're gonna
worry about that I got the best
commercial agent at the time I gotta
copy the Taco Bell commercial all that
[__] SBV at the time of the best
commercial agents in town maybe seven
and yes I got very lucky with them I saw
them at improv and they signed me but
theatrically for movies and television
I couldn't get [__] signed by anybody
nobody was [__] side
nobody even a couple years ago after I
did grudge match when my agent was
thinking of leaving his agent I didn't
think I was gonna get invited and I
reached out to a bunch of agents and a
bunch of agents hit me back but they're
like we want to sign a theatrical don't
want to even talk to you and I'm like
dog I got a [__] number 3000 and I am
DB and they didn't want to talk to me is
is that maybe why her messages upset you
a little bit because you know how hard
it was for you to get an agent it's not
her messages it's a lot of people's
messages and a lot of people's attitudes
that bother me right because I don't
really think they understand what goes
into this
or anything that they gonna do I mean
you had a situation where you had a
friend that went to school that went to
law school and thought they were gonna
come out and
a 40-hour week and there's gonna be
people drinking margaritas and jumping
up and down a weekend and when they find
out that they had to work every other
Saturday and they found out this job you
know that's a realization well they sell
it to eat every movie or TV show and
obviously they have to make them
entertaining but they make work look
easy I get eight hours of going to lunch
and playing tricks on each other nothing
like they don't show that it's like
fighting traffic your and then your boss
asks you to do something at 4:45 on
Friday when they had it all day and like
they don't show they don't they make it
seem more exciting and fun in the day
and that's like the thing that just
never it's very monotonous the outcome
do you believe when they say that we
changed my generation do you believe
like in terms Millennials and all that
uh yeah I mean I'm just looking at how
like my mom was with me and how her
brothers and sisters act and then seeing
how young parents a little bit like they
have kids a little older than you now
treat them differently so I don't know
exactly what levels but yeah I think
just based on the time people grew up in
they act differently I mean listen I
always hear terms I don't want to sound
like one of these [__] idiots because
I gotta be honest to you at the age of
there was nothing I wanted to do at the
age of 20 21 22
there was nothing I wanted to do it was
really enough nothing I want that was
interesting to me I mean yes I was
interested in the law but as far as
work-wise work was the farthest thing
from my mind I can't write anybody I did
not want to work and I was confused I'm
telling you I didn't get unconfused so
1984 the confusion that I had the 934
was that somebody was gonna make a call
they were gonna get me a job
and I was gonna make a hundred thousand
a year plus working 35 hours a week and
not busting my balls I thought I have I
I thought that I had it coming today I
thought because of my mom dying and my
situation that I thought that somebody
was gonna hand me a life you know and
then in 84 I realized that nobody really
hands your life
nobody hands your [__] unless you're
born and you're following the fruit
market and his father had it before then
and you grow into it but those first
couple of years you got to pick fruit
and work and still cut the lawn and
still deal with customers and the whole
thing then eventually it becomes yours
but unless you have that you're gonna
work I didn't know that like most people
learned that you learned that at 16 you
know I was waiting for a payday if I
work three days of a construction site
is because I was waiting on a payday
that was coming I didn't know from where
you know I mean it there's paying back
to it though like it's and I'm not
anywhere near good at it now but I'm
just barely learning is like those kind
of drug I got a job I think at 14 as
soon as I could I think I got a permit
but that didn't it made me not very good
at being entrepreneurial and working I
was I'm good I'm a lot better when
someone's are here this is what we're
doing today or this like this is your
what you have to do and when it's just
here you do all of it and decide what
part we're gonna start on like and
that's where the doubt you talked about
earlier comes in is when you when you're
forced to make all the decisions and
since you didn't you were all constantly
making decisions so you got good at it
and I think going from high school to
college and working those corporate jobs
there's really not I mean you have to
decide what classes you're gonna take
but once you decide roughly what job you
want to do they tell you what classes
you have to take and then you get to do
a few electives but even then they don't
really count so it's funny that I use
life the same way okay so they tell you
if you want to be an attorney you have
to have a degree in history and you have
to take a lot of math because it's
problems out so I've used that in life
sometimes like I've always said it I'll
say it once I say ten thousand times I
became a better comic since I started
you Jitsu why because it makes me solve
problems well I'm on my back and there's
a guy on top of me I have to decide
whether I got a retain guard try to get
him into the half guard or try to sweep
him those little things you know where
my daughter trains for Muay Thai and all
that [__] they have a few autistic kids
and I see how they start with them they
put them in a different class and they
start a very slow with them and I see
them picking up muscle memory stuff like
that they pick it up and it's it's the
same thing that's why I do all the
things I do even though I'm a stand-up
because I want my mind to move my mind
features are only writing and performing
I wanted to do something else
so for my mind yeah I go there to lose
weight to be healthy and so I don't turn
into a fat fat [__] I go to jujitsu but
I also go because it makes me think and
once you stop thinking so do you see how
you use your Jitsu just like a college
you know I go to Muay Thai training the
other days I do that because it makes
you think about combinations and
uppercuts and looking at weaknesses so
Lee likes to keep his left hand low I'm
gonna throw overhand right - Adam you
know it teaches you different strategies
hat so all these strategies are useful
to attack life you just applying them in
a different way oh yeah I mean that it
totally makes sense it's just I think
it's what you're talking
the beginning is the hard part is
applying it on a consistent basis on a
consistent basis and that's once you
apply anything like that you know I've
been when I first went to the counselor
he's like well you got to take physics
and this there's another type of math
you have to take and I'm like why right
I'm becoming an eternity I don't want to
take that [__] oh I want to be a [__]
that was something else I was going for
once they were once they pick the
attorney from me I wanted to try into
something else and that had physics
something some type of math I just did
not understand and they go because it's
problem-solving when you're on a stage
and you're a comic your problem solving
yeah do you come up with two jokes and
they suck you got to figure out how to
get them to like you and I'm gonna get
them to take the ride with you you know
if and it goes for anything you know if
you're a carpenter and yeah it's gonna
take you a while to get used to hold you
know when you work in the winter it's
completely different than working in the
winter than what it is working in the
someone you're a carpenter right plus
going back to a little bit about what we
talked about or what you talked about
last podcast it's like how different for
you was when you were being an
electrician when your boss was there
versus the first time you were there by
yourself like you had to make all the
disappointing up and he couldn't lean on
someone else that's a big moment for
well I'll tell you what
at that age I wanted more money so when
he left I went to work I went to work
one thing about me was I always took
pride in my work from learning I had a
good work ethic I try to do that with my
daughter now you know my daughter out
for my wife my daughter helps me she got
a little while and some of my wife
already I told him a few more months she
can help me you know I picked the bottom
out of here Oh
we'll figure out where to hide it and
they could have a come clean the table
I'll help her vacuum pick up the chairs
dust we'll take it out and I'll pay
attend but my mom did a good job and
then the neighborhood did a good job
after that
because there was always jobs in my
neighborhood and I learned something
from every single job you know I'll
never forget I applied for Rendell
lumber and marine and I went down there
I told them
who'd sent me the guy gave me a [__]
an application I filled it out and then
it goes give me five minutes for a
second he went somewhere he came back
and he was come here to follow me and he
took me in the back and he goes I'm
gonna pay you for a few hours worth it I
just want to see how you work I want you
to move these two rooms around put that
here put that stuff to have a little
money left and I looked at both rooms
now I'll never forget was gonna just
sweep and move the boxes something I
came up with and I said wait a second
this is for a job this is for my life
let me do this the right way so I wonder
the first room I took the boxes whatever
boxes he had and then I put them all in
the middle and I swept around the
[__] sides I slept all the walls then
I took the boxes from the other room
within sighs water I put them all up
against the wall ba ba ba and then I put
these back and then I swept all that
[__] into the middle I picked it up and
I went in the other room when I swept
every corner everything and picked it up
I went downstairs and I go what else can
I don't think we should done already
because you're probably didn't do a good
job I don't never forget we went
upstairs and the first thing he did was
move the boxes to see if I slept behind
the boxes oh [__] he goes you getting
the job he goes you don't know how many
people came in for this job and didn't
sweep behind the boxes he goes I had a
guy do the outside yesterday he goes why
don't people move stuff when they Sui
I have learned that from mr. bender
growing up sure that you got to moved
the box like he was goofing on his son
one day about one of the boxes and he
was gonna move the bow or something
we're talking about the drop we're
moving the draw
downstairs and Josie's hallway his aunt
Josie had a hallway in the laundry room
down there there was a beer and I'll
never forget that we just picked it up
he's like no you gotta sweep behind that
so from that lesson I learned to pick up
the boxes and sweep if I wouldn't have
slept behind those boxes I wouldn't they
got the job cuz I would have showed the
man I was lazy what and even that age my
mother was dead already
my mother was dead already when I got
the rental job that's why I got the
rental job my mother at Dinah ray so
even at that age I was always not
intuitive but I knew that when you work
you work I don't like people telling me
what to do I never like people saying to
me hey don't forget to clean above the
TV hey don't forget to do that hey don't
forget to handle [__] like that [__]
so you just do it so I just do it so
that I don't say I just do it way before
they ask me I know they're gonna ask me
right they're gonna ask me anyway so why
am I waiting so good boy I mean it's it
takes a while I think to know what
they're looking for I guess it depending
on what you're doing but a hard work was
a hard worker something who's got
initiative you know we mean we have
great conversations we always know who
has a podcast what we call them and
invite them to do the podcast area 10
minutes before the podcast starts people
who don't have a podcast get here a
half-hour before the podcast start you
can always tell who has a podcast you
know it's little things you know you
gotta be in a job later o'clock you're
there to correlate that's it not five
date not tenth day you're there to
coordinate that's if you wanna race
you wanna rage you gotta be the first
guy they had the last guy that delete it
when you wanna and that was my mentality
even at that age you got to be the first
one here and the last one here yeah yeah
I mean it makes sense you got a show you
have to give them no they don't just
give raises out because they have to no
no and then that's people like
initiative people like not telling
people what to do I don't like telling
somebody what to do I don't want to tell
you every month hey wipe the door down
can't you you go to a restaurant you're
gonna get something to go in the glass
is fingerprints on it yeah so not one of
those I always go on those restaurants
and I count that look at how many
employees are working and then go down
one of these [__] geniuses thought
about going over there and cleaning that
glass then on the other hand I go [__]
that glass these poor bastards probably
make eight bucks allow 8,000 now but
then I go [__] to $8 an hour you should
do that just representing yourself if
they don't want to do it [__] them but
you're gonna do it because you're better
than there so do you understand the
school of thought I came from yeah why
should I wipe that glass it's [__]
subway they're gonna dirty in an hour
you know what [__] it I'm not gonna wipe
that glass cuz all I get is $9 now first
tips you know what I'm wiping that glass
cuz some day I'm gonna have a restaurant
and I want that I want the customers to
see that everything is clean every time
not gonna eat in your restaurant of the
glass is [__] dirty how do you get
the flu by touching things by touching
things so how can the glass be dirty in
the [__] restaurant if your glass is
dirty
what's your kitchen look like what's
your [__] or your [__] you dick look
look smell like you've got to assume no
it's true it's true and then how often
cuz will complain when it's bad but
every once in a while there's a guy or a
girl who you work with or you see at a
store and they're just amazing they're
just full well like there's there's
nothing worse than having someone when
you go in there like be rude to you or
not even care be like
good you know I come my wife one time I
go customer service has gone down the
hole in this country am I mad at
customer service a little bit but I'm
also mad at the amount that they pay
these people and what they're willing to
make them do when the sacrifices we
don't see you know they hire you now for
20 hours or not to give you insurance oh
yeah how much enthusiasm would you have
knowing that you don't have my back you
don't have my back you don't have my
back there's a corporation you got no
[__] insurance cuz you're gonna hire
god forbid I work 21 hours and you have
to give me insurance so if you steal
from those people they deserve it they
gotta come from them and trust me I've
stolen from a lot of businesses I work
but there was a lot of businesses I went
to work for that I saw that there would
be some people so I gave him a lot of
percent of what I had even if that's not
my job even if cleaning that glass I'd
love to do with me I'm the type of guy
who clean the glass because that
represents who we are that door
represents who we are and that's it
that's the problem everybody the only
want to do their job do the job we don't
we sell it on Duncan's podcast five
years ago other people didn't do what
people do when people aren't looking
that's character
nobody's looking then let me let me pick
up the floor because the Channel 4 News
is on the corner and if they see me
giving away free food at the Laugh
Factory don't think I'm a good person
do you know I'm saying anybody could do
that all right anybody could do that
pull over when there's nobody around go
to gym in Johnny's or whatever and get a
veteran sandwich what's that the chain
over here Tony and lemons you know in
Jersey Jersey Mike's ok Jersey - do you
like homeless people that much go buy a
sandwich and give it personally to a
homeless person that's a way like
there's nobody watching that's a weird
thing people are doing now is the venue
of themselves giving stuff yeah that's
[__] video dr. snow bear I've made
fun of those people in that hunt I
pulled over there the one man I gave
them all in 20 even though I beep out of
more with him than you and their clan
they're not there yeah Christmas dad
gave me a 20 apiece
why not I beep out of my scare the [__]
items
in a shopping cart you gotta take care
of these people you understand I got the
black guy but 20 every time I see it the
black Vietnam okay look he's like your
bodyguard he's I got him on call
surprises make you see him more often
like I'm surprised you didn't know your
schedule I was homeless and someone gave
me 20 bucks I see him all the time
okay I just pull over when I'm in the
mood when I see him but he's close to me
that I have to make a u-turn the sound I
pull over ask him how he's doing if I
got waters I'll give him a water from
the car
you know what the [__] and I don't want
nobody to see it I don't nobody needs to
see it nobody needs to see that you
donated a charitable don't hate all that
[__] you do if you want to do it out of
your heart not because somebody wants to
see it you know it almost makes it seem
like I guess it's still a good thing it
helps people but it just maybe it makes
you look gross when people have like all
the news stories about it and that's
people want you to think that there's
someone there not well you good person
you just want them to do it and that's
it nobody needs to know nothing as long
as you know it that you're doing the
right thing by your friends and you try
that's all that [__] matters that you
don't have to take facebook pictures and
put pictures up there you know the
[__] hugging them you know but
that's what people think but going back
to what we opened up with it's the truth
we all come to a realization and then we
have to do something about it and all a
lot of youse listen to the podcast and
you say to yourself [__] you know maybe
he's got a point I don't know what my
next step is you do know what your next
step is you would definitely know what
your next step is you just not you don't
want to face that [__] mirror you
don't want to go into that water well
there's something to happen you're gonna
have to go into that water
trust me it's scary but we all have to
do it we all have to do that thing we
don't want the most and then once you do
it you realize this wasn't so [__]
bad what was I so [__] scared of he
was scared of [__] that maybe
something good might happen once
rafi we're all scared that maybe if I do
this something [__] good might happen
maybe I might lose 10 pounds maybe my
diabetes might go away maybe I will get
on that [__] shell maybe maybe maybe
these are all the things you [__]
have you know so using once you come to
the realization of what the [__] is
really gonna happen then you'll know I'm
not telling you to quit your [__] job
or quit school or quit whatever and it's
nothing don't quit nothing make sure
make sure how do you make sure you know
it in your [__] balls but before you
jump you know there's two sides to this
coin after you jump you can't look up
but before you jump I want you to look
down and know what you're jumping into
when I jumped into comedy I had asked
[__] 10 million questions and there's
no bigger [__] than me in the world
there's no bigger [__] nobody is scared
of what things that I had and I put my
head down I said you know what I'm gonna
eat this [__] because I know the quicker
I eat this [__] the quicker I'll get out
of these [__] woods and here we are
27 years later and that's it that's that
so there's something you feel that you
want to do deep down in your balls yeah
look at the ocean look at it from all
angles before you jump in there's
nothing wrong with that before you spend
two or three hundred thousand dollars
for our house you get an inspector you
get people to come over you get the roof
guy you get the [__] the street guy
that make sure there's no cracks in the
foundation
why shouldn't you check out something
from head to toe before you jump into it
I just want you to know that once you
jump you can't look up just stay stay
with your head down and listen man I
couldn't quit comedy I had thirty
thousand reasons a quick nominee 30,000
30,000 when I got in nobody wanted to
sign me Ralphie got signed just what
kind of deal Brodie got an agent
everybody had [__] I was the last guy to
go but then the little agent signed me
and I started doing good things with the
that the little bigger agent Simon I
started doing bigger things at that
agent meanwhile there's no Tommy I'm
still doing comedy at the store and all
this thing and I'm doing [__] taxi
with Queen Latifah time doing funk and
Sam Raimi spider-man then I got Adam
Sandler's and nothing then I get my name
is Errol and [__] nothing then
there's a strike I was thinking of like
18 episodes and there's a [__] strike
and you know listen you put your head
down you put that fireman hat on and
shits gonna bounce over your head and
just go off your shoulder and I
guarantee you I guarantee you that
you'll come close to whatever goal you
have you know it's funny in 97 before I
got arrested and my war had a picture of
a Testarossa of fur ah a Ferrari
Testarossa and when I started working
that took molded Toyota that's the first
thing Jim handy said to me was what are
your goals I think oh I want a Ferrari
Testarossa that's the way you say it I
don't even know it's the white car with
the [__] dingy Lamborghini
Lamborghini whatever the [__] it is
I cut a picture up I put it on my wall
somebody told me if you want some kind
of picture out and put in your wall and
that's what I did for years guess when I
got nothing and when I started working
at Bull Toyota one day he asked me what
I wanted I'm like yeah I want to test
the roads in the Lamborghini and he goes
write down what you gonna do to get it
and he [__] stop me
he stuck me first I had to find out what
the car cost
I didn't low-cost 300,000 thousand this
is in 1988 87 and then I actually sat
down on paper and I figured out what I
had to make a month to pay for this
[__] car that's how much of an idiot
I was so I was like I'm gonna have to
sell 27 cars a month you know and he's
like this is not what I want you to
write down I want you to write down how
you gonna come up with the money to buy
see understand trying to say to you you
gotta simplify your goal simplify it
this Monday I wrote goals and guess what
they were simple like tomorrow I hit him
I got a couple different goals every
week I got like six or seven different
goals every week right six hours right
six hours
for workouts break the 72 points on
weight watches if I stay in town make
sure you do five spots a week I have a
thousand goals that on Sunday night I
look at my notebook do two podcast you
know every [__] week every [__]
Sunday night I write a new set and every
Sunday night I check off the [__]
week and I swear to God if I write 11
things down I do terrible I swear to God
and the only reason why I don't finish
maybe I'm gonna doctor for blood tests
you know I'm scared of that [__] I
always leave one off the list like this
week I got blood test on her again but I
woke up late this morning I got some
money and there's I got something to ten
I'll never make it back in case i faint
but I gotta lift weights I'll never make
it back but at least I always stick to
those [__] goals people
so remember realization what you want to
do then get down but to get down you got
to write those [__] goals and you're
sitting there going Joe we've heard this
already from your my write the goals you
never heard about the roofers I didn't
think about it till this week about what
happened to me in 1984 and how I didn't
do anything about it till 90 [__]
three I prepared for that though do you
see I'm saying by looking into the well
I looked into it for nine years before I
jumped okay I'm a half of fact then you
got me some people we should take two
years it took me nine years but I still
jumped and after this podcast was about
was gone for it's a beginning of the
year it's January 24th lot of years have
lost your eye already you've given up
maybe you told yourself you can't do it
you're not gonna do it you don't think
you do it [__] that [__]
I'm here to tell you is the 24th get
back on it if you [__] one off you
die get back on it if you want to get
back on it you know what just keep
showing up just keep showing up and
eventually one [__] day day you'll be
and how do I know cuz I [__] lived it
that's how I [__] know
don't forget [__] tonight I'm at the
brand [__] improv with George
Perez
and my main man and I don't even know
what his [__] name is Mikami store
Saturday night sold that all you got is
Thursday early a couple tickets that
there's Friday late and Thursday is
still tickets available all you got
there do not forget I am in San Jose
Valentine's Day weekend and then the
following Friday I'm at Treasure Isle in
Las Vegas and that there 23rd I'm at the
Fox Theatre in Tucson Arizona I want to
thank the Flying Jew I want to thank
[__] you guys for listening most of
all I gotta thank my sponsors give me a
minute here and this week we got some
great sponsors as far as that's
concerned let me tell you something I
love [__] Robin Hood I love what they
do
my wife is more into it than I am but I
love when she shows me the app on the
phone I mean it is tremendous you like
joy what the hell is Robin Hood Robin
Hood is an investing app then lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs and options and
all kryptos ready for this one
commission free they strive to make some
financial services work for everybody
not just wealthy people not just people
drive testarossa's but guys like you
guys like me it's a non intimidating way
for stock market newcomers to invest for
the first time the first time with true
confidence the app is simple and
intuitive it's gonna clear design with
the data presented and easy to digest
way other brokers charge of the $10
fairy trade but in Robin Hood they don't
charge Commission fees trade stocks they
let you keep all your profits when my
wife shows it to me it's easy to
understand charts and market data place
the train and just four taps on your
smartphone you ready so you can place a
tap I'll trade in four taps Robin a
platform also lets you view stock
collections sectors like entertainment
and social media and curated categories
like female CEOs analyst ratings of by
old and self every stock the most
important
thing about Romulan this is this is you
know my friend Dean lip reats into this
stuff you'd learn how to invest as you
build a portfolio a lot of you guys are
young you don't have a portfolio now is
this time time to work I mean you don't
need thousands of thousands of dollars
you discover new top new stocks and
favorite companies with personalized
newsfeed and you also get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right moment to invest
this is the way to go Robin Hood is the
way to go so what I'm gonna do is this
okay
Robin Hood is giving the church family a
free stock like apple for the sprint to
help build your portfolio sign up in
church dot Robin Hood com that's church
dot Robin Hood dot-com no Commission no
fees and it's a non intimidating way for
stock market newcomers to invest for the
first time with true confidence go to
church dot Robin Hood com that's church
dot Robin Hood dot-com the other spots
on this is somebody something I brought
a product I just fell in love with quit
take that but you're starting a healthy
routine this year you stick it to it and
the two dairy very different things
inevitable we all skimp on the full
night's sleep we skip on a workout of
two or you brush your teeth with a tired
old toothbrush that ends right now
we're not perfect but we can do better
and quit is the better electronic
toothbrush it's the best electric
toothbrush that can help you how do I
know because I use it my daughter uses
it my wife uses the bristles are
fantastic they feel mine they feel great
your mouth feels refreshed they have a
timer so you know how long you're
spending on your teeth you put the fiber
the three it is tremendous all right why
do people love quip so much people brush
too hard someone like your toothbrushes
are too abrasive two-minute timer pulses
every 30 seconds to remind you when to
switch size and to help you clean your
whole mouth evenly up to 90% of us do
not brush for a full two minutes
we don't even clean evenly Multi covers
works understand
to me reason slides over your bristles
to pack and protect the equipment the
clutters your Cinco cabinet makes
traveling with an electric toothbrush a
lot easier plus there's no wires a
clunky charge it it runs for ready for
this three months on a single charge
brush heads are automatically delivered
and a dentist recommended schedule of
every three months for just five hours a
friendly reminder why it's time for a
refresh and stay committed to all health
seventy-five of us use old worn-out
bristles that are ineffective I was
until I got quit clip is one of the
first electric toothbrushes accepted by
the American Dental Association and
they're backed by over twenty five
thousand dental professionals and they
have thousands of thousands of five-star
verified reviews all right now like I
told you guys I love quipped why the
bristles the timer and it's easy to
travel that's why I love quip ok and
this is why there's over a million happy
healthy mouth do also so what I'm going
to do this clip start to twenty five
hours and if you go to get quick calm
slash Joey right now I'm gonna give you
first refill pack for free that's right
go to get quick calm slash Joey right
now and get your first refill pack for
free that's your first refill pack free
that get quick calm slash Joey
I want to thank quip I want to thank
Robin Hood
I want to thank zip recruiter I want to
thank stamps.com I want to thank on it I
want to thank all our sponsors but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
taking the ride with us you know I love
you [__] see you Monday morning
nice and early ready to go whoo doop de
doop if not I'll see you tonight
tomorrow night or Saturday night and
Bray California at the improv
don't forget eight o'clock tonight 7:30
and 7 o'clock on Saturday nights at and
I sold that so you [__] I love you
[__] stay black have a great
rest of the week and have a great
weekend
see you Monday morning ready all right
kick this [__] mule Lee